so bill de blasio's been out of the
front page for about five months he's no
longer the mayor of new york he's got
nothing to do
smoking a little weed watching on
netflix he's bored so he's going to run
for office again
he's going to run for congress from new
york
what's that going to look like well to
mark the occasion we want to run through
some of his biggest moments as the mayor
of the city of new york back in 2014
this is our favorite he celebrated
groundhog day by killing the groundhog
this footage from groundhog day 2014
shows freshly inaugurated mayor bill de
blasio appearing to drop staten island
chuck a week after the de blasio fumble
the groundhog did a few more events
before being found in zeus space
deceased on february 9th
you should have known he was going to do
to midtown what he did
to the ground dog which he did
by 2019 he became completely demented
and started talking like a chipmunk
remember this we're doing something that
should have done a long time ago in this
country we're passing legislation this
year
to guarantee working people like every
other industrialized country in the
world to guarantee working people by law
two weeks paid vacation every year
so he was scraping the bong res and ran
out of that so he started taking hits
off a helium balloon then one of the
weirdest moments of all came last may
when he announced that shake shack would
give away free food
people who got the covent shot cause
more burgers that's gonna get you
through the pandemic watch
do you say
free fries when you get vaccinated
um
i got vaccinated
you're saying i can get this
delicious fries
just think of this when you think of
vaccinations
oxidation
he's so high i mean it's just it's just
unbelievable jimmy fallon is the host of
fox across america with jimmy fallon
joins us jimmy are you excited for the
return of this man well listen i can't
blame him for trying again it's hard to
get a gig tucker when the only thing
you've been endorsed for on linkedin is
killing groundhogs and trashing cities
it doesn't look the best but i have to
correct you i hate to be a fact checker
here but he didn't kill the groundhog
actually what happened is after being
seen with him publicly the groundhog
died of embarrassment it wasn't the fall
he took a look at those poll numbers
when de blasio ran for president and the
campaign died quicker than a carnival
goldfish because of what he's done to
this city and i want to start there okay
new york city and the idea that he has
the nerve to ask for anyone's vote after
what he did to new york new york city
right now tucker looks like gotham
before batman comes except batman's not
coming because he's not vaccinated he
ain't showing up they're like you got to
go back to wayne manor i'm sorry six
feet of space will fight the crime
virtually and that's the issue like my
family was gonna come to new york city
this weekend but they decided to go
someplace safer like beirut because this
idiot who ran the city into the ground
was always and always going for the
performative stupidity creating the
appearance that he cared and he was
doing something a good example of that
was that vaccine video where he's
stuffing his face with french fries hey
tucker what's the leading killer from
covid obesity so we're combating vaccine
hesitancy by encouraging fried food
consumption this is like combating arson
by giving away a book of matches man and
the one thing i would say to that is
maybe uh the one upside to the biden
presidency is arson is down because no
one can burn down your house at 5 15 a
gallon they gotta really love you to do
it but as far as de blasio goes man
hilarious he implemented a vaccine
mandate in times square on new year's
eve man on new year's eve like tucker if
you're partying in times square on new
year's eve covent is not a top 10 germ
you're worried about catching you know
you're actually like relieved when you
got it okay but that's new york in a
nutshell for the midwest new york and
most blue cities are run by stupid
people who think they're smarter than
you which is why right now with our
subway in the condition that it's in
tucker we just opened up a 30 million
dollar staircase on the new york city
subway and i know a lot of people
watching are like wow jimmy tucker 30
million's a lot for a staircase but i
should remind you that it also doubles
as a restroom and a place to shoot
heroin so you're getting like a three
for one deal here and that's why it's so
disgusting the city is gross okay and if
you really cared about it you don't
build a stairway into the subway you
actually like clean up the subway tucker
have you ever ridden the one train and
not seen someone fondling themselves
like every time i swipe my card i feel
like i'm entering a zoom with jeffrey
toobin come on man
i can't add to that jimmy great to see
you man see you buddy